لسنوات عديدة ، كان ديفيد آدامز يحارب
مرضًا لم يتم التعرف عليه بعد ،
لا يمكنك محاربة عدوك
الآن ، فهو يحمل اسم متلازمة فيكسوس ،
وهو اضطراب التهابي ناتج عن
طفرات في جين uba1
لخلايا الدم واكتسبها لاحقًا في الحياة
وفقًا  بالنسبة للمعاهد الوطنية للصحة ،
يمكن أن يتسبب في حدوث طفح جلدي مؤلم وآلام
وتورم في الأذن والأنف
والسعال وضيق في التنفس.تورم المفاصل
وآلام والتهاب
الأوعية الدموية غالبًا ما يعاني المرضى من الحمى والتعب
الشديد ، فقد
كان ذلك حراً للغاية.
وجدت دراسة جديدة نشرت في مجلة الجمعية الطبية الأمريكية أن متلازمة فيكسوس أكثر
شيوعًا مما كان يعتقد سابقًا
يعتقد الباحثون أنها تصيب أكثر من
ثلاثة عشر ألف رجل وحوالي 2300
امرأة في الولايات المتحدة إذا كنت
فردًا أكبر سنًا مصابًا بنقص الدم.  يحسب أن
الالتهاب الجهازي
لم يكن قادرًا على الحصول على تشخيص ويتطلب
المنشطات ، نعتقد أنه يجب عليك
الخروج والتحدث إلى طبيبك حول
إجراء اختبار جيني لمتلازمة uba1 و
dexa في الوقت الحالي ، لا يوجد
علاج قياسي لل vexis ولكن
يمكن علاج الالتهاب باستخدام
المنشطات ومثبطات المناعة الأخرى
للصحة دقيقة أنا آندي جاثر